on n' pas de système de chauffage dans
la maison et pourtant on est à 18,8° en
plein hiver alors qu'il faisit moins un
ce matin cette maison c'est la maison la
plus performante du monde on a été primé
à la cop24 en Pologne c'est une maison à
haute performance énergétique sur
lesquelles on a 36,5 cm de béton
cellulaire et à l'extérieur on a 20 cm
de polystyrène en gros on a un mur de 65
cm donc qui est très isolant et avec des
menuseries en triple vitrage ça va nous
permettre de chauffer la maison grâce au
soleil donc avec des ouvertures plein
sud et peu d'ouverture au nord et donc
ce soleil va rentrer et il va chauffer
par exemple la dalle en béton cette
dalle en béton va nous permettre
d'accumuler de la chaleur ce qu'on
appelle l'inertie et cette chaleur va
être redistribuée tout au long de de la
journée et de la nuit donc à peu près 60
% du chauffage vient de du soleil et le
reste ça vient par exemple de bah quand
on cuisine en gros les apports internes
la cuisine la chaleur corporelle les
chargeurs de téléphone la télé la
machine à laver tout ça ça va
correspondre à peu près à 40 % des
besoins chauffage de la maison par
exemple si on cuisine avec le four à la
fin nous on va laisser le le four ouvert
pour que que la chaleur se diffuse et ça
nous permet de bah d'avoir une maison
qui est extrêmement confortable sans
avoir à payer de de chauffage 30 % la
consommation d'un foyer moyen en France
l'électricité lié au chauffage donc ne
pas avoir en payé c'est quand même
l'idéal bah tout à l'heure il faisait
18,8 et là il fait
19,4 le temps de grosso modo bah de
faire du riz quoi et puis après les les
poils qui sont chaudes surtout si tu
cuisines avec de la fonte ça va
redistribuer de la chaleur en continue
pendant une heure ou de donc là
actuellement chez nous il fait 19°gr
cependant cette température de 19° elle
serait plutôt équivalente à 21°r dans
une maison traditionnelle pour la simple
et bonne raison qu'on a que 1 degré
d'écart dans cette pièce entre le sol et
le plafond et dans une maison
traditionnelle on va plutôt avoir 15°g
d'écart entre le sol et le plafond ce
qui crée un sentiment d'inconfort on a
froid au pied on a plutôt chaud à la
tête l'air devient sec avec les
radiateurs donc dans une maison comme
celle-ci on a plus ce problème là il y a
pas de zone froide dans la maison si on
passe à côté des baes vitrées on n pas
de différence de température on a cette
sensation de confort en fait qui est
encore plus extrême dans la maison qu'on
a à côté là-bas qui est l'ffet en
isolation en botte de paille parce qu'on
a un mur qui a été enduit en terre et ça
permet vraiment de lisser la température
almost
ready donc là on est dans la chambre de
Maina on remarquera qu'il y a des
bouches de soufflage dans la chambre une
ventilation double flux ça va nous
permettre de recycler la chaleur c'est
vraiment on recycle la chaleur qu'on a
produit au préalable dans la maison le
reste c'est du traditionnel là on est
vraiment sur des murs en placau de la
faillance du parquet au sol l'idée c'est
de faire une maison qui n'it pas
d'impact environnemental ou le moins
possible et aussi et surtout de maison
confortable et c'est clairement ce qu'on
a réussi à faire ça fait 3 ans que je
vis dans la maison moi et pour rien au
monde je retouris dans une maison
traditionnelle la maison elle fait aux
alentours des 240 m² à la base cette
maison avait été conçue pour accueillir
des clients potentiels pour développer
les maisons passives sauf que maintenant
on y vit donc donc si c'était à refaire
la maison serait plus petite il y aurait
une seule salle de bain et non trois
tout aurait été fait différemment alors
là on est dans la chambre d'amis ici on
a la salle de bain aussi Qui est qui est
intégrée dans la chambre on a même une
une baignoire bal néo l'objectif c'était
de montrer que bien qu'on soit en plein
milieu des bois qu'on soit totalement en
réseau on puisse avoir une maison qui
soit d'un point de vue thermique
extrêmement confortable et d'un point de
vue énergétique totalement
autosuffisante si tu regardes là-bas là
il y a les il y a les panneaux
photovoltaïques qui vont nous permettre
de produire l'électricité pour le site
avec un système de batterie et cetera de
se dire qu'on peut avoir une maison
extrêmement écologique qui qui n'a
quasiment pas d'impact sur
l'environnement euh sans être un un un
écolo extrémiste donc on peut avoir une
balle néo chez soi qui consomme 3500 W à
l'instantané hein ce qui est énorme euh
mais vivent dans une maison qui n'a
quasiment pas d'impact sur
l'environnement pour la simple et bonne
raison que on récupère notre pluie on a
un forage sur une nae fratique qui passe
dans le terrain euh on produit l'énergie
avec des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
sont garantis 30 ans et qui sont
recyclables à 100 % enfin on est à 96 %
donc cette maison a été réalisée en 2017
après plus de 6 mois de recherche et
développement on est on est reparti de
zéro en fait sur la conception d'une
maison et dans la foulée on a fait
l'autre maison qui est à 50 m là-bas et
on se rend compte qu'on atteint les
mêmes performances avec du biosourcé
sans utiliser les matériaux
traditionnels qu'on pourrait acheter
chez n'importe quel fournisseur du
bâtiment avec du béton cellulaire du
polystyrène et cetera donc celle-ci qui
a un aspect beaucoup plus contemporain
et en fait réalisé avec des techniques
qui sont au final plus vieilles dans ces
murs c'est uniquement des bottes de
paille et on voit bien si on regarde
l'épaisseur du mur en fait à l'intérieur
l'épaisseur du mur c'est c'est
clairement la la largeur d'une botte de
paille donc lorsqu'on a réalisé les
maisons on sortait à 3450 € du m carré
TTC clé en main pour une maison avec des
matériaux traditionnels et pour une
maison biosourcée avec une isolation
paille avec des performances
équivalentes on était à 2000 € du mère
carré TTC clé en main donc on a
quasiment divisé par de en ayant un
bilan carbone si on prend en compte le
CO2 qui a été stocké dans la boîte de
paille qui est stocké dans le mur et qui
ne va pas bouger on a un bilan carbone
qui est qui est génial et là la chambre
est à l'étage autant dire que il y a une
une vue assez sympa quand on se réveille
le matin
tu es là
pas pour quelqu'un qui connaît pas le
bâtiment c'est impossible de savoir que
cette maison en paille la finition en
plaque de plâtre c'est une cuisine
traditionnelle c'est clairement
important de pouvoir faire une finition
contemporaine et standard on va dire
similaire à une maison à parpin parce
que les gens vite des a priori peuvent
vite mettre la la construction paille
dans dans des cases en se disant que
c'est c'est de l'habitat alternatif
c'est pas performant ça peut brûler
enfin il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
désinformations et beaucoup de rumeurs
sur la paille alors qu'en fait on on y
obtient un confort de vie qui est
vraiment incomparable dans le sens où
les les murs perspire on a vraiment une
une migration dehumidité de l'intériur
vers l'extérieur on a on a une chaleur
qui est qui est vraiment optimale et en
plus si on doit être amené à démolir
l'habitation on y fait un tas de compost
et c'est parti il y a pas évacuer les
déchets enfin c'est évidemment il y aura
les fenêtres les machines à laver ces
choses là mais le le plus gros du bâti
c'est c'est de la matière carbonée c'est
c'est c'est de l'engrais pour le pour le
terrain à la
finale à la base on était une entreprise
générale du bâtiment on a obtenu après
un an et demi d'acharnement les
autorisations pour faire la maison
passive mais avec des matériaux
traditionnels puis une fois qu'on a
réalisé la maison saturbois avec une
isolation biosourcée en botte de paille
on a voulu ne faire que ça et on a
jamais réussi à obtenir les assurances
et les prix dans le biosourcé ils ont
vraiment flambé de manière inexplicable
he parce que le bois a pris 300 % alors
que le béton a pris 5 % le bois est fait
en France le béton vient de je ne sais
où derrière c'était compliqué pour les
clients d'avoir d'avoir des crédits et
de s'assurer euh on a on a clairement on
a baissé les
bras là on est dans le poulailler la
première phase c'était de faire des
maisons à haute performance énergétique
donc très peu énergivore et là
maintenant on est en train de développer
l'autonomie alimentaire donc on vient
d'aller voir le le poulailler il y a du
marichage qui se fait un peu partout et
on a aussi les cochons les Gascons qui
sont qui sont là-haut à la base l'idée
c'était de montrer qu'on peut faire des
des des grandes résidences avec 10 15 20
habitations et et avoir aussi un potager
partagé avoir un un jardin partagé et
faire en sorte que les habitants de ce
type d'écoovillage puissent être
autosuffisant sur bah déjà la totalité
de leurs besoins énergétiques et aussi
leurs besoins en eau puis par la suite
s'ils ont envie en fonction de du temps
qu'ils ont envie d'y consacrer euh de
gagner en autonomie d'un point de vue
euh
[Musique]
alimentaire